hey what's up everybody just a quick
reminder the most recent 15 episodes are
available on itunes and youtube to get
the rest of the ru garbage library
please go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg that's right to save
a couple of bucks we get to wet our beak
and you get the full access to all shows
on the network's libraries it's a good
deal
do it we love you welcome to another
exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley oh baby
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is
are you garbage the show where we sit
down with your favorite comedians and
fun if they grew up classy
or if they're a big old piece of trash
i'm your host age foley coming at you on
a glorious day here gas digital studios
we're in the big studio we got a big get
and we could not be more excited
my co-host everybody's best pal i mean
let's forget about it
the next time you're reaching for a
buddy you go ahead and make it a kippy
because this kid's all right
kevin james ryan everybody thanks big
man i'm happy you pulled out the cabana
wear for the big guests too this guy
shout out to the george collection at
walmart catch you down in del boca vista
pretty soon
uh we'll drop a grand in disney world
like that what's up everybody thanks for
tuning in we appreciate it as always
please make sure you review subscribe on
itunes uh keep us in the top 200 and
also
uh full video available on youtube you
can subscribe there as well
yes sir and gang we could not
now i say this a lot in the podcast but
we don't mean it for the other guests
those other bozos forget about it
zakamiko who
we could not be more excited to have
this very special guest on the show with
us today
that's why we're in the big studio baby
well they don't move you over here
usually
no we're over there yeah we chose the
little one oh keep our egos you know
what i mean keep the ego and check
that's what we've been telling you get
more times over there yeah nobody kicks
you out like we need it like nobody
needs it
exactly gang that voice you hear has
appeared on the conan o'brien show brody
stevens enjoy it kill tony
35 episodes of this is not happening
plus 46 episodes
executive producer seen him on the
bonfire last call with carson daly the
joe rogan experience
and of course legion of skanks he has
multiple stand-up specials out to name a
few he has passive aggressive paid
regular
and double negative he's the host of
skeptic tank and has also appeared
in the hit film keeping up with the
joneses
which me and my girlfriend watching
tonight and thoroughly enjoyed it
you'll find that i usually i i have
forced my way that off my
uh uh let's go resume and bio
ladies and gentlemen give a [ __ ] big
round of applause for the one
the only mr ari shafir thanks for having
me you guys yeah man thank you guys to
be
here before i even start i'd like to say
that uh let not letting gas digital
people have their own patreons like you
guys
the equivalent of dana white not
allowing the ufc fighters to have their
own sponsorships it's ridiculous and i
don't stand for it i love you lois i
don't i don't
we don't if we don't we don't know this
guy this guy
we're very happy here yeah what about
classy or trashy
i don't know it just seemed like it
would rhyme yeah i don't know no not for
the title
just when your intro you say are they
classy or are they trash
i know because we say it in the in the
in the it's in the it's in the voice
already
so i try not to say the same thing and i
like to play with it mix it up a little
bit
it's good yeah that's right yeah keep
the writers
what's your breakdown of trash versus
class most people are garbage
but i think we've had a handful like
verzi was garbage pulled out of garbage
jared fried was just [ __ ] he's like i
mean i can tell you that no he's class
he's
yeah you're a writing system i mean he
might do he might do trashy things
he eats cheese plates but like he's he
came for money
he was like country club like he was
very i mean then also like in comparison
look at zac amiko you know what i mean
like there's a there's a wide range of
it
good point you know in comparison for a
comedian maybe sure exactly for comedian
plates
i don't know what that i don't know if
he knows what that meant
you don't worry about the other guys
we're going to find out if you're trash
or not
that's good which we don't know i'm
you're i'm complicated man
i'm leaning he plays it fast and loose
with some things for sure yes
there's been like pee throw in and you
know a lot of that's true
that's that's definitely not glass jared
freed ain't throwing his piss i'll tell
you that much
but also a very structured individual
you know what i mean
what like you know he he doesn't like
trashy [ __ ]
hill yeah you're very and you're also
very opinionate you have a stance on a
lot of
behavior a lot of things a lot of brands
i presume
you're you have a staunch opinion on
stance heavy
that's what they say about you in this
street funny guy big dick stance heavy
yeah big old pee
pee that's a [ __ ] point in your favor
i'll pay it out i love the shirt by the
way i love a good uh hawaiian shirt
thank you
thank you it's the george collection at
walmart i'm telling you if you're a
husky guy
get over there because they're going
like hotcakes they got everything
bathing suits
tank tops the works yeah i like this
shirt underneath the
shirt too because you know you're gonna
it doesn't button yeah that's why
that's the fat guy i like how you blame
it on the shirt
yeah it doesn't matter that's the button
i'm not huge it doesn't
matter i see the whole goddamn it's
broken
all right tell us the back story here i
want to know your origin story where you
grew up how you grew up i want to hear
the whole thing
i grew up in uh in uh north carolina and
then maryland
uh orthodox jewish orthodoxy for that
time yeah the the
the yamakas the plates on the head okay
now what's the difference between
orthodox and hasidic
pacific will be the black hats the
soccer jews and bed style and [ __ ] yeah
like the coats and stuff the heavy coats
that's acidic
okay yeah that movie on uh show
unorthodox yeah those are hasidic people
okay
so you didn't rock that when you were a
kid no we had that was a peripheral to
that we were heavy orthodox so it was
like it's like a
you know it's like a thing here and then
the thing here and we're like at the top
end of our little ortho like the
venn diagram there was some overlap
maybe yeah it's like you know how
there's like basic sitcoms like boring
stick and then there's like cool ones
like it's always sunny and stuff like
that and it's like it's like everybody
loves ray was like a basic second but
like the best version of him sure
and then you got like life on a stick
which is like the worst version of that
but still in that like shitty nothing
sitcom sure
sure you know cause i live up i live up
in the heights by yeshiva
oh yeah yeah yeah oh no [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah yeah one yeah that's why i lost my
religion when i was at yeshiva
university
were you you live up there how what's
the neighborhood like now what is it
like 100 what is it
it's like 185th in amsterdam yeah yeah i
live at 190th and st
nick what's your exact address uh yeah
wait you lot you lost your religion yeah
well he's not orthodox anymore take a
look at him i am not
i think it's far from it yeah bacon on
fridays here we go
i could take this off so very like if
the family was very religious obviously
like by the by the book or did you guys
like buy the cool book
i bought the actual book shabbos the
whole nine yards yeah it's
lights out on friday you leave them on
or they're off oh
they get i mean i don't know if you know
but just shove it's clocks where you can
set your
light to automatically turn off at a
certain time i heard you guys got like
fancy phones too that you can like all
the doctors yeah yeah where'd you hear
that doctors and and uh we had a an
ambassador
in my community it automatically picks
up the phone every like
20 seconds and so once it's already
picked up because all
right it's like the spark or something
sparkling yeah you can't start a fire on
the shabbos because there's
there's like seven there's you can't
work on the sabbath sure right and then
in addition to not working they give you
seven
jobs like these are what we're talking
about these jobs oh so like scribe is
one
you know that was a job back then so
like even if you're not a scribe
you can't write on the sabbath no one
can run because that's like a
job another one was fire starter so
that's no candles
no you gotta if you leave them on you
leave them on you can't touch them you
can't even like mix like
movies oh so you can leave the lights on
you just can't [ __ ] with them you can't
[ __ ] yeah uh
they're very crafty too you guys like i
remember like people like they'll have
like neighborhood kids come in and like
turn the lights on in brooklyn and [ __ ]
was going yeah you hit strongly at the
fact that it's too bright in there
you're just like ah it sure is i wish
the lights could go off so i could sleep
you can't say it because then it's kind
of like you're doing it oh and it can't
be a jew it has to be a full boy
shop wow yeah somebody said like they
pulled it don't get one of the catholics
i forget who it was it like pulled them
in the house and they were like point
just because they guess they couldn't
say like turn the tv off can't say it
you could just hint that but they were
just like yeah
and he was like just touching things
like i don't know what you want me to do
man yeah on an elevator if you ever got
on an elevator and i was like oh i gotta
walk the steps i wish someone could hit
the floor eight for me
what are you gonna do and then i'd be
like i can do it for you like if you
want but you can't say hit flurry for me
wow
yeah and it can't be a less religious
jew has but by the way it's only because
you guys don't have that law so you're
not sinning
sure okay yeah yeah we can't ask you to
murder for us
because you got that law sure it's wide
open over here we can you know
minus the ten rules we can do whatever
the [ __ ] you would be a hero to your
community if you're like
if you just go by an orthodox jerk if
you see him like hey if there's any
lights you find annoying let me know
what they are
and i'll see what i can do about it wow
i don't know will they tell you will
they hit you
yeah dude i would have been out at like
age 10 i would feel like [ __ ] this
yeah it's probably duck hunt fox novel
shovel and snow turn off some lights
all right so you lived in an orthodox
jewish community yeah sabbath the whole
thing
keep kosher pray three times a day when
did you when did you guys move from
north carolina to maryland
fourth grade into third grade from one
community to the next yeah
so it was a strong religious growing
yeah just religious um
and then it's just like all the way
through i finished uh finished uh high
school
okay i went to a seminary in jerusalem
for a couple years yeah
yeah um lived there that was great and
then came back went to
your neighborhood yeah to yu what were
you gonna do what what do you
what would you become a rabbi possibly
probably not though you go to seminary
if you can become a rabbi and you also
go there if you just like
want to be devout yeah if you just want
to be you know
it's like where'd you guys grow up
christian catholic anything catholic
catholic you know
so there's like really religious people
but they're not priests yeah they'll
like they'll teach like ccd or whatever
those dudes were always [ __ ] yeah
they [ __ ] scared the [ __ ] or just
some people go to serps you know church
every
day and do the studying and stuff like
that where it's like they're not a
priest but
they have a more jews are like that okay
um so but if you want to become a rabbi
you'd do the same thing
damn and then so when you got to yeshiva
university you decided started thinking
about it i didn't realize i didn't
believe in god so
i was kind of out wow how'd your family
take that not well
at least you could turn the lights off
for him now no i can't ma
why not i'm a jew yeah so it's all j
it's not he said if it's
even if you're not less of a jew you
can't do it uh so if if their bathroom
light is
off and i turn it on they can't use that
bathroom for the rest of the sabbath
what yeah they can't benefit off a sin
of a jew
it's like nazi research yeah there you
go yeah it makes sense
holy [ __ ] dude yeah so you wouldn't even
be able to like use it
you don't even have the opportunity to
be garbage at that point like what can
you really i mean i feel like the the
rules
in that upbringing it's tough although i
mean i don't know there's there's still
certain growth stuff there's nothing to
do with religion
sure do you wipe your ass do you go you
know i don't i don't know what you're
doing yeah yeah yeah
chew your fingernails or is that against
the rules you might get the rules so
that's like that could be a garbage
thing
yeah we did fit simmons the other day
and he he bites it and then
eats the stuff under and picks his teeth
with the nail what'd you have on
zoom zoom yeah yeah wow pretty gross
he had some real guards did he bring up
that he hit his kids he almost got him
taken away
he did not no oh it was like a year ago
it was like a big thing
i would think it would come up in this i
think you're you have to be [ __ ] with
them no
hey i think he was like punishing them
and then one of them like
said something to a teacher public
knowledge all right i'm never
telling you a [ __ ] thing i'm pretty
sure it is i don't know
but anyway yeah i'm gonna rule out a
jewish rule keeping your [ __ ] mouth
shut his whole wife's family had to like
testify on his behalf or something i
don't know the exact stuff but it was it
was a really it was a problem for him
for a while
i see he's deflecting right now you know
he's deflecting that's a
talk about good stiff guy really [ __ ]
up stay away from me
let's get back to it so do you still
talk to your family yeah yeah yeah they
said they came it's close with it after
a while yeah
okay it took a bit now like if you go
over there on a friday night you're not
like [ __ ] your headphones on
[ __ ] flicking play by the totally
respectful yeah the same if i went over
to muslim's house or catholic's house
you know i'd rape a kid with you guys
or whatever i don't know whatever you
guys are into but like you know chuck a
beer get pregnant
call memorial day let's do it yeah i've
seen the biggest catholic are they still
in they're still in maryland uh-huh okay
yeah so growing up was it like a single
family house or an apartment or a town
house house house proper
jews brothers and sisters uh-huh how
many sisters and a brother they're all
they're all pretty my brother's not so
religious anymore either but the other
ones are like
with tons of kids damn um yeah it's just
like
what was the snack situation growing
could have been good not great
but that was just us i think my mom was
like
something to do with like safety or
something in college like she was like i
don't know in like pre-med or something
so like she was like no sugar foods but
other people in the community had like
twizzlers and [ __ ]
we'd always go over there yeah yeah we
had like
the best we ever got was honey nut
cheerios oh
yeah that was me eating healthy though
that was like trying to pull back from
the lucky charms
or something it was like the best we got
no ice cream nothing like that
tofutti which was like food soy based
ice cream oh my god oh yeah
it'll be another country that's against
about sure
yeah yeah yeah yeah but like it just
wasn't great you couldn't mix meat and
milk so if we had a meat dish
you couldn't have dairy for six hours
afterwards so
yeah unless we go down to basketball
drinks milk with dinner so there's no
way he could be jewish yeah
it wasn't a great life but we didn't
know any better was your mom a good cook
yeah for sure my dad is a great cook now
so the jewish food that you guys had was
good because
it was solid it wasn't gross yeah yeah i
mean some of it was like super ethnic
where you wouldn't even like filter fish
if you're not into it you'd be like this
is disgusting i could never have this
but almost everything else i'm down with
because i've eaten a lot of choppers
dinners
i mean uh i've had yeah i've had that
that's a good one yeah
it sucked though the the broad making it
didn't know it didn't their way around a
frying pan or whatever
yeah that's that's the thing when you're
like jews are like this like well
there's better than worse ones you know
yeah of course yeah so like something
like jewish cook
food sucks like no that lady doesn't
know what it was she was like irish or
something and she married a jewish guy
so she tried to learn how to make it for
him and
they were like kev stay over we're
having like our jewish dinner i'm like
all right
like two bites in i was like yo ma come
scoop me it's
never gonna happen it's like it's like a
jujitsu guy trying to stand up at 31.
yeah it's just you can't do it my buddy
did that he converted to judaism
uh to marry his wife he was hardcore
lutheran
all growing up really converted now he's
hardcore jewish
i don't know if he's orthodox but i know
he lives in a in a community
yeah it makes sense yeah they tend to
they tend to they stay closed dude
they gotta convert and like yeah it
seems like a lot of hoops get catholic
it's you know i'm going to be raised my
hail mary's and you're in my wife's
jewish so we're going to be
oh really we're going to be doing what
are you going to do i'm not converting
no she's not like
hardcore joe she's eastern europe like
she just moved here from
europe so she's like she's coming to box
yes
buy one get one free wayfair promo code
garbage everybody
uh do you still have a patreon or you're
just like
disabling it or you were holding up no
we're it's the same it's we're on the
network okay let me ask you a question
though what if you had
what if you had this podcast sure and
you had another podcast not on guests
the kippy and foley show or something
yeah uh yeah
uh let's say you're an individual person
could you have your own patreon for you
as a performer i'm sure yeah yeah yeah
we have to check our contract yeah it's
just for the show we just not yet it's
just speaking to mr gomez it's just for
the show
all right hey we love it we're happy
yeah gas digital
dylan dump this
[Laughter]
yeah if you're watching the whole thing
for sure that's never happened he loves
his kids sorry
that's what he was talking about he's
like yeah i wrestle with my kids all the
time and i'm like maybe i got a little
too far maybe he headbutted him or
something you know
my god all right let's get into some
[ __ ] garbage questions here we got
the backstory
he's currently smoking smoking doobies
in the studio
what the [ __ ] shut up ralph would hear
you left i think
what oh great i mean the only honestly
the only person that could tell you no
is dylan and i don't
know dude i have like this weird level i
don't know what to do either i honestly
think
ari could tell me no at this point i
think arya could um
actually say no to smoking weed in
someone else's studio garbage pretty
trashy literally what are you gonna do
even if i wasn't like a
like a valued member of the gas family
what would you do if i was just some new
guy would you drag me out of here like
what would be the i worked the door at
the comedy store
but yeah you're not going to do anything
if i said you got to leave and somebody
goes no i'd be like you called my bluff
i played my only hand i got yeah if i
walked in there and said hey you have to
leave
right now you would just keep smoking
yeah i mean you're not going to visit
you're not going to physically remove
them yeah i'd be like i'll [ __ ] call
the cops cause jordan be out by then
call the authorities i know my rights
i'm jewish
i don't play by your laws i'm jewish i
can do whatever i want i asked that once
at a tsa
they were like the line was forever and
i just went up to the lady i was like
where's the jewish line
there's one around here where is it
there's got to be a shorter one you know
with the snacks
where's the chosen line damn
that's pretty good all right smoking
weed in the studio this guy
does see this is well this is kind of my
theory on you a little bit
and it actually lines up uh very much
with zach
zach grew up [ __ ] like wasn't allowed
to do it was like
strictly strict household as you like
crazy strict if they took the doors off
the apartment in the off
off the bedrooms and [ __ ] like what do
you mean like there was no doors in the
house because he was religious
no no religious just [ __ ] wacko
parents mom was psycho
psycho like no doors couldn't jerk
couldn't eat had to eat over the sink
like just wild [ __ ]
so i think the strictness and then when
you turn 20 21 whatever and you're like
i'm getting the [ __ ] out of here
it's [ __ ] balls to the wall i'm doing
whatever the smoking that's very
impossible make up for a lot of time
did you go crazy not crazy but did you
not right
now since then it was like yeah for sure
like made up for lots of version till 23
and then like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] from 26 until like i mean pretty
much now did you not smoke weed or
anything no
before you can't william cerroyan says
that the human comedy says well there is
anyone who has religion force on him uh
will never accept it and goes further
the other way yeah that's where that's
uh that's exactly what i think
is you know because you're like i'll do
whatever the [ __ ] i want though you
can't tell me what to do
not even don't tell me what to do it's
like i def i challenge you to tell me to
stop smoking weed right now yeah i have
a problem that way yeah
so he just quoted a writer that's pretty
classical he's you're an educated man
right yeah where'd you go to college you
went to the university of maryland
university of maryland
was the term what was it yeah i
transferred from yu to over there to
like state school because i was like i
don't know
is this before yeshiva or after after
yeshiva so after seminary which i also
called yeshiva then you go to
yu for a year yeshiva university mm-hmm
21.
that was here that was up here yeah and
then i was like oh this is something i
don't want to do this and
like why pay for a college where it's
like four hours of religious studies a
day
yeah i don't believe in it so i just
transferred to in-state nice in state of
maryland that's the next year next year
yeah
state schools you went from that to
[ __ ] the universe you must have been
going [ __ ] crazy
no because it was a little bit like what
my going crazy was was like
your guys yeah kind of like oh we're
gonna get a beer
and hang out i'm gonna get a bb two
drinks yeah hello we're [ __ ] crazy
yeah somebody's just cigarette
i did it yeah yeah that's what we were
doing when i was like 11. you know
you know i was like stealing my friend's
dad's weed and [ __ ] it's tough to see
arya's like a nerd like that yeah
because he's so [ __ ] he went so far
left i just i thought it was recently
like when i got to the comedy store when
i got to la to start doing comedy i
didn't realize until like recently i was
four years removed from super religious
orthodox judaism and then coming with
those like joey diaz like cocaine
degenerates that's crazy you know
thieves and [ __ ]
vagabonds and they're just like yeah i
couldn't know what the [ __ ] that was and
then they got me even like
[ __ ] yeah yeah damn that's [ __ ]
complex man yeah a very special episode
i'd like to know
what the trash or class is in terms of
like is it just like dress or is like do
you stand up for your friends and [ __ ]
you know
well it goes it all it's all we we're
you know
we're honestly we're connoisseurs of
garbage right right so like
wait your answer we don't have to we
it's just in us we don't have to
be like oh what do you think we both
just react the same way for some reason
about garbage
sure we have like a very good we're
dialed in on it so it's like
it's also like kind of like brands of
[ __ ] you buy where you try to save money
where you spend money
like that kind of [ __ ] as well as like
your upbringing but your upbringing so
it's mainly we're going to be judging
you i guess from like 20
on kind of okay yeah where you are now
yeah exactly sure yeah
yeah sure yeah you got a young hitler
was a nice kid
good painter yeah yeah yeah better than
us to be honest
people say it wasn't great better than
any of us let's get into it a little bit
okay first question all right even
though it's a jewish community
which we say possibly cannot be garbage
i just don't think it's too strict to be
garbage
what was the name of the street you grew
up on uh early on was pebble
pebble street that's not too bad that's
a sleep that pebbles
that's how you decide what garbage no we
just get a feel for it
we're getting our feet in the water yeah
yeah yeah figuring out a little i know
that's true but if you live on [ __ ]
steve's turnpike that's a good sign if
you live on like a bypass like we just
had potter on he was on like
south union he was on the throughway he
lived like next to the toll booth
i'll tell you i didn't know apartments
were a thing until i saw it in a sitcom
class when i was like that's class
didn't know apartments were a thing
was your television and all that stuff
limited as far as what you could watch
and what you were exposed to in the
outside basically we only have basic
television no cable for a while no no no
no we could we if we were a friend's
house we could watch it yeah okay and
now we're like
oh what i just i thought there was rooms
until like slowly became like oh they
live that's a whole
living situation where's the there's no
upstairs where's the basement there's
also apartments like different strokes
that makes sense
sure yeah yeah yeah so did you have a
garage
oh yeah okay did you have a do you have
a refrigerator in the garage
uh yeah too actually
uh um a dairy enough and a meat uh
garage
oh that's really they have to be
separated no but we just made it that
way but still
two or three or four four last one
capri suns like ice pops
that was all that's all religious you
can't be doing that honestly the
the garage fridges that was just like
when we got
really good deals on like frozen oh [ __ ]
yeah so that would all fill up
exactly what it is but two garage
fridges that's a that's a [ __ ] ayg
first dude and a laundry room fridge
what what yeah you get four
get this guy another joint huh get him a
bubbler or something
saying it out loud it it does seem
strange that's [ __ ] classy yeah we
got multiple fridges
yeah that'll probably be the best fridge
game
growing up did your folks have a little
bit of cash you have a little cash
growing up
i okay middle class i think it was more
functional my dad's a survivor so he's
like i'm not going to throw away a
[ __ ] fridge it still works that way
let's see that's the garbage mentality
yeah
that's so nobody goes out and buys a new
fridge the garbage mentality in you goes
this is a refrigerator i can't throw out
a fridge so you just stick it in the
basement or
somehow use it somehow yeah except the
fact when you think like no one else
needs a second or third or fourth fridge
yeah
you'll do without it of course yeah yeah
it's it's garbage mentality but it is
also like clean living at the end of the
day you got multiple fridges you know
have you guys ever gone to shopping and
then taking the stuff when you're like
you have you know get ice cream or
whatever get some frozen stuff and try
to fill up the freezer here in new york
there's not much space and realize like
oh we got to eat some freezer food
tonight
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like
there's not enough room let's make some
room or even the trashier thing
is just to unbox it and put it back in
you know what i mean like take the texas
toast out of the box they're like oh
crumple up the bags you know what i mean
that's a good move yeah
buddy we're trash
yeah freezer burn foods the [ __ ]
worst all right pebble street
all right i got a family i got another
basic what'd you get on your sats
ooh what'd you get 11 11 40. 1250.
this guy i don't know this guy hold on
how old are you i
i didn't take this the 2400 uh i'm 33.
that was the new sats what are the new
sats well now i think they have a new
newest these the new sats were
same thing they did with women's fashion
but the new sets were the scores weren't
high enough
so across america so they just changed
it to make it a bit easier
so um if you got like a 1200 that would
be like the equivalent of getting the
1300 before
so now 1200 just means more so you just
everyone just do better
yeah no i took the same ones you i took
the same i mean i think they changed
like five years after me i think you
might have taken the new ones
would be a 10.50 to me and myself yeah
so you're a [ __ ] idiot it's out of
2600
no no it was still out of it it was out
of 1600 1600 still this is the first
time here they changed them after me
and then changed them again so they
changed them twice i think they went to
2400 and then changed them again so i
think
for a while they were saying the
questions were racist
who was sad questions for racist
juan's washing his clothes down at the
rivers yeah they didn't use words like
that or something like that's people
like i don't know black kids don't know
how to like
who's what's what's who's adam is that
the cop or something
yeah anyway 1250 old sats you would have
seen it as a 13
we're gonna have to we're gonna have to
look into that 12.50 that's pretty good
quote and authors
three [ __ ] fridges and extra freezers
like study program yeah i never took
that yeah so that's a 1250 that's a real
time that's a raw 1250.
no juice did it naturally did you take
them once or multiple times just once
yeah do you have any pets growing up no
no pets at all oh i think young young we
had like until like
first or second grade we had a dog for a
little like vague memory of a dog but
really young hmm okay you know what i
got him i took a practice lsat
but that's on a weird don't you get like
a six or something on that aren't they
weird out of seven what's this what's
the scale
lsat is that a 750 i don't have no idea
what is the yell says that to be a
lawyer my mom's not a lawyer i'm lucky i
took the sats to be i was gonna stop at
the psg so you were gonna be a lawyer
too no my friend was and he was
practicing all the time for the bar and
not the bar just to get in for the lsats
like non-stop blue and kaplan [ __ ] and
then i beat him on a practice test
dylan's got the average score is like
150 so 120 to 180 does that sound right
yeah i got a 170. yeah 73. 172. he was
at 172.
he could have won dylan what's the
highest yeah that's what i got turns
into
ah yeah oh is it 170 170 yeah that's
what i got a couple more than that um
all right we got to crack this guy we
got to get him
i got one yeah go ahead have you ever
been at the gas station and used the
squeegee to clean anything but your
windshield
absolutely yes that's [ __ ]
doing your wheels or something that's
trash all right shaving with it
one of my first bits when i was like two
years into comedy that's a bit washed
you know you're poor when you wash your
entire car with her
dude i caught my my wife was like yeah
why don't you just get the door i'm like
i can't [ __ ] do that i'm like i just
can't
you gotta put you're like well i have
time it's still filling up even though
you know it stopped yeah you know you
only put six bucks in you know i [ __ ]
do the inside i put take a couple paper
towels too i'll tell you guys
yeah why not oh it's trash also it's fun
to use it it is fun you feel like a man
when you're
it's like a thing you saw people doing
wipers yeah
but also you're not going to get a car
wash that's out of the picture and you
see it once you go once in the door and
it really cleans the difference you know
it's like the dessonex and you're like
of course do the whole thing
that is good trash behavior though real
quick gang let's take a second and talk
about today's sponsor
real paper real paper is here to make
sure that you never run
out of toilet paper ever again
no more emergency trips to the store no
more random napkins
gross very gross even during the
pandemic
reel has made sure that their
subscribers have toilet paper
they make incredible soft three-ply
toilet paper delivered straight to your
door not only is real super soft and
durable
but it's also made entirely out of
sustainable bamboo
and i love that even reels packaging is
great
it's great for the environment and since
they don't use plastic
that's a pretty good thing with real you
can pick and choose
when you get your shipment so you'll
never run out of toilet paper again
nope not even once and the best part
about
real for every roll of toilet paper you
buy
real helps people in need to get access
to clean toilets and buddy that's clean
living right there that's awesome
2.4 billion around the world don't have
access to a safe toilet and real wants
to bring that number down to zero
because they're good
peeps and you can help if you're a good
peep you can help just by wiping your
butt with real paper
you you clean your butt they take care
of the rest you know what i mean so go
to realpaper.com
that's r e e l p a p e
r dot com and if you use the code
garbage
that's garbage you'll get 10 off a
single purchase of your subscription
order
plus free shipping in the us of a baby
that's realpaper.com use the promo code
garbage
and do some good for the world by wiping
your butt all right
let's get back to the show yes sir all
right so we got him we're gonna
we gotta stay in this wheelhouse we're
gonna stay in the wheelhouse okay that
wasn't since
all right you know it's penalty he's
qualifying it
have you ever gotten cash back while
making a purchase
ever yeah yeah but like is it a habit no
twice ever i think wants to see if it
would work like two years ago
is this really a thing um i don't i
always don't believe it either
that's a class and then once i'm like oh
i got to give somebody some cash for
something so i was like hey can you give
me 20 bucks back off this
hmm all right pretty good that's a
science maybe
you're right well like lewis does it
every time he makes that's the only way
he gets cash what no what about spot pay
oh lewis this guy's taking shots on
everybody i doubt
i have tons of cash from spa pay all the
time no one in new york would take
let me ask you this you want you what
take a shower i have yeah for sure
all right that's good all right
next question take three days three days
makes you feel like you're under attack
sometimes like by congress
do you wash your hair first or last
wash my hair first yeah it's good this
guy checks out man
that's tough this guy's tough okay crack
i got one he's got the pace slow we're
all discombobulated
he's got me contact i don't know what's
going on that guy came in and gassed us
what do you guys do are these the same
questions of different people you do
they're different for everybody
sometimes they over like you know but i
mean it's out of a pool of like a
thousand questions your fans like write
in questions
yeah like insane go to patreon.com
are you garbage oh garbage that's right
this guy's all hopped up on his
truck it's all hopped up on doobies
when you go to a restaurant like a nicer
restaurant yeah well you order the
specials
sometimes that's classy i don't even
listen to them really really
oh i'm student we're such blue collar
trash that it's like
so we're not that's a rip-off don't even
keep your head down don't make eye
contact and keep it moving
hamburger they don't tell you the price
with the you gotta remember the price
you want to compare like well that's a
little better but not for 33 versus 21.
yeah exactly so like when you get the
bill like i'm sure my mom did it and my
dad got the bill and it was like [ __ ]
you know
42 for the lobster bisque or something
and she caught a [ __ ] and they say
that so
some restaurants don't have the prices
at all on that at all
and they say that's classy but i think
that's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] also they do that with like beers
are like five
six and then without mixed drinks they
just don't list them yeah like what the
[ __ ]
i know i think cause it fluctuates so
much you know what i mean they're like
hey today they're 11 tomorrow they're
nine
yeah hey um you know my dad was date my
mom she said that at nice restaurants
they would have the
price only on the men's menu and not on
the women's
at jewish restaurants or just in general
wait there's different gendered menus
yeah because it was so classy they
weren't religious for a little while
like like the met i guess so they would
go like regular restaurants wow
but like uh yeah because the woman
shouldn't the woman yeah
what that's pretty good let's go back to
that
right right women i'm sure there's seven
listeners you know that are women would
be like uh
with like i wouldn't mind that yeah yeah
yeah the women that listen to this
for sure wouldn't mind that for sure
my mom's still gonna pay though right
yeah it doesn't my my wife's only
getting the chicken figures that's all
uh let's see here here's the okay joey
diaz says specials
that's food that's about to go bad
they're trying to get rid of that's also
true they gotta get it they gotta get it
moving
do you think that's true or that it's
like no the chef is trying something if
it works out and it's good we're gonna
put on the menu it depends where it is
probably at a diner they gotta get it
they gotta [ __ ] get rid of it right
right if you go to like a nice place it
was bought with a chef like a proper
chef it was bought that day they're
trying to you know
try something yeah i worked at a nice
restaurant it's 100 sure
yeah that is what they're throwing out
sure the idea is
you especially even nice even a nice
restaurant they'll over buy so let's say
they buy like a lot of stuff
yeah even like our family meal like the
staff meal yeah was
always stuff that was over bought over
got so whatever that special is
they bought too much of that that way
yeah what if it's like a fish it's not
even on the menu
still frozen oh right so they gotta get
rid of it no nice place no i'm saying
like
they don't overbuy that do they wait but
sometimes but yeah
sometimes a chef will just buy things
because like they'll they're also
curating meals
yeah that's happened once again a nice
restaurant will like change the
menu often yeah okay but is the food let
me ask you a further question
is that is that meat bad already or
they're like hey dude we got like two
days later we have too much of this
yeah no no it's not necessarily that's
bad
but sometimes it is definitely the the
idea of a special
yeah is to that restaurant is to not
lose money or lose product on the
product
right so like i think the idea of a
special to me at least is like it might
not taste as good as you think because
they're just throwing [ __ ] together but
also like
when a girl when she's like hey the
broccoli is going to go about so let me
make some food tonight it's not just
like the shitty broccoli it's like maybe
she's like i have a new recipe
you got to make room in the freezer yeah
you know what i mean
i can't decide got me thinking about
staff meal at work did you ever wait
tables or anything
um what were your jobs comedy store yeah
for a long time
and then just like a bunch of temping so
like i delivered i mean
summer jobs but like job jobs i worked
at a health network it's an assistant
for a while
assistant for like a the president and
the vice president
just got him coffee and [ __ ] yeah i
hated it
that's white collar [ __ ] you're not
[ __ ] you're not out there with a
double trailer
roofing in the [ __ ] summer oh no no i
worked at our international cemetery one
year
you worked where arlington national
cemetery really yeah that was my like
white blue colorist job i mean damn
digging graves
no laying pipe ooh yeah he was just take
these giant pipes
and [ __ ] that was fun when it was too
hot the graves would be real cool the
open graves they'd have openly dick
guards yeah you and your friends and
just chill out
that's [ __ ] that's trash that's trash
you're playing yeah yeah
man see he's [ __ ] he's right there on
the line and then all the stuff
can't get a read on this guy yeah um all
right you're up big man have you ever
been to colonial williamsburg
oh yeah oh that's a trashy busch gardens
i think so yeah
did you guys ever go to a wax museum uh
i have been to
one before not us the family but i
haven't the one in hollywood
uh madame tussauds yeah
too but i don't go every year would you
guys go to uh colonial winsburg and
busch gardens as like a hulk squad
that was a family one time to colonial
williamsburg with the cousins and
everything yeah
just uh just us and i think i feel like
it was an upscale trip at the time
you gotta understand that's [ __ ] trash
[ __ ] is different now than it was then
i'll give you that a little bit the
[ __ ] busch gardens was trashed back
in the 80s
yeah it's still trash today yeah the
wicked wolf or whatever the [ __ ] yeah
take a [ __ ] hike with that i'll be at
thorny park in the [ __ ] lazy river
yeah good point maybe chloe's work was
actually always trying
to guarantee you yeah i just didn't
think of it that way yeah cool
on vacation to watch somebody churn
butter yeah right oh dude
that's worse than amish country cause
they're faking it at least the amish
country you're watching them do it yeah
like educational like that's what they
told you the brochure you idiot
some fake blacksmith hitting a hammer on
a sword or something
see i knew we were gonna get it all
right we're getting we're getting them
we're getting them
um let's see
have you ever i got one have you ever
asked the bartender what the cheapest
beer is
i don't i don't think so okay now you
don't she doesn't you don't strike me as
somebody that's cheap
i've been hooked for the cheapest beer
on the board sure that's different
you're like hey how much is a blood
light or something yeah
add him in his ass he doesn't i'm sure
he doesn't like go in and like uh
think about it yeah that's tough that's
tough that dude asking a bartender they
immediately you're that's the first and
last beer you're getting
because they know they're not getting a
good tip out of it you know what brody
tommy
just go to the bar [ __ ] drop a 10 or
20 right there like i'll figure out what
i want in a second that's for you and
just uh
oh yeah that's a classy yeah and they
can always get over poured always get
served first yeah that's good
i go like if i'm going out with like a
group of like if we're like walking to a
bar i always hit them heavy the first
time
of course you know that's smart and then
they'll like they at least you know i'm
definitely not leaving on my 20 or
something but like they're getting
they know me they know there's there's
there's water in the well daddy
yeah yeah the 10 20s if you know you're
going to be there for like a few hours
sure but then i also do as i get like
lower like it's like three o'clock in
the morning like all right there's
zero tip on that yeah come on i've been
wetting your beak all night
put the first one in half can you loan
me a five yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] cut that first 20. they have two
tens with his buybacks
do you own a metal detector i do not own
a metal detector no
a police scanner no have you ever used a
t-shirt gun
i have not no i would like to
sure who wouldn't that shows garbage
tendencies right there have you were you
have you ever tried to learn or did you
know at any point the devil sticks
i've i knew them a little bit a little
bit
i know man that kid nobody wanted to
hang out with that kid
that's why you didn't need him you're
busy it's a [ __ ] one-man sport
no that's a chicken or the egg thing
they stopped hanging out with you would
you juggle
boom what would you juggle
[ __ ] candid hair pink again it was
blue two days ago what what's he doing
oh midlife crisis yeah did you juggle
did i can you yeah i could juggle
i could juggle three have you ever
juggled in public
oh yeah sure dude um you trash do you
keep your
batteries in the refrigerator oh he's
juggling
wow that's a lighter a paperclip and
keys
that was pretty good those are very
separate weights
there's like a big jewish onion this guy
a lot of [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] yeah i'm not bad i took that
klutz book of uh
of of a juggling remember that no
he's pretty good that's a couple thanks
what are you talking about two awful
ones i need
like like waiting i know dude catching
too
there we go oh that's it you got to get
in the room once you hit that first
rhythm you can you can keep it rolling
it helps if they're all the same size or
weight that's an old george burns bit
i'm not buying that's pretty good and
it's not the fact that you can't juggle
but it's [ __ ] garbage if i walked
through a park and looked over
and saw you with the [ __ ] devil
sticks oh yeah dude the devil sticks
there's that's enough to come back from
got him oh yeah
um it was good do you keep your
batteries in the refrigerator
never oh that's good that's a garbage
can that's real trash [ __ ] cause does
that even like
work it's not a [ __ ] banana i don't
know norman says no he still does it
though
do you do you have a drawer with uh like
ketchup packets and
all that almost always there's ketchup
packets at your
apartment now in new york city probably
like
upscalier um uh uh whatever
accoutrements but like should i have in
bottles
okay i don't need it whatever it is but
it like came with delivery or something
yeah then you're like let's not waste it
i don't know who knows
who knows when you'll need some ketchup
packets have you ever cooked
with uh leftovers with like leftover
takeout
like combined two dishes absolutely yes
cause i was poor for a long time it's
true i get it but
you gotta be garbage hey how did
beginning comics get by in new york city
work you gotta work day jobs everybody
yeah
for years you have to but even that like
what kind of day jobs did you have at 22
that could [ __ ] pay
for 25 or whatever they could even like
pay your rent here well a lot of
expensive here
a lot of them yeah i mean well you're
like a lot of them are also just living
in a room for like 600 bucks like on the
window and it's like way up either up
uptown or [ __ ] deep in brooklyn and
[ __ ] oh 600 you could swing you can
swing like
but like yeah you don't start getting
paid in new york and then even when you
don't
earlier than la you get paid here but
the costs are so much lower there yeah
um but yeah it's tough it's tough for
the first like [ __ ] five years yeah
no comics don't make money in la for
five years
no no wait it takes a long time yeah
well i mean like
even the ones that get on it takes five
years you know what i mean here it's
like
it's like that's the guy who's out doing
like [ __ ] six mics a night
damn um all right have you ever cooked
eggs in the microwave
yes ugh ari see come on recently
trash no not recently but um like what
do you put on a paper what do you put in
tupperware or something
well one uh at target they had a egg
poacher
microwave egg poacher that's trash that
was great
they're trying to poach eggs in the
[ __ ] microwave it's great it works
exactly you cover
at all yeah yeah yeah yeah there's also
there's no there's much from that a
bacon thing in the microwave
i've heard that's good but bacon bacon's
great in the microwave
i disagree and that is not garbage
you're buying a [ __ ] egg poacher at
target that's trash dude come on yeah
it made poached eggs what are you gonna
make poachers
garbage just make the poached eggs i
don't want to make poached eggs you
don't do it in the microwave i'll tell
you that much
you boil some water you turn it off you
put a little bit of vinegar
then you spin it around where'd you grew
up the [ __ ]
the palace in new england vinegar you
had it
shut up
oh [ __ ] have you ever played on a
softball team
yeah uh sure okay yeah that's trash
okay yeah yeah the after work softball
yeah yeah that's real yeah that's tough
one i mean unless it's like a beer
where it's just like a fun like it
depends i feel like they can go either
way but i'm also
my dad did one for a long time a
softball team that's that's a little
different that's a community-based thing
yeah you got
you guys some of these questions are
about a guy who no longer exists
what do you mean i mean a [ __ ] dead
ari who's not here anymore
an old version you're judging them
things are wild you're still you baby
that's that
you're saying that's in you that's right
if you're talking about background
that's one thing but if you're like
judging me i'm like doing that now
i mean i don't know make your own
decision you just juggled you just
juggled
you played you used the devil sticks you
wash your car with the squeegee
but you do got nine refrigerators at the
house do you have a car right now
no i don't you don't um what was your
last car when i left la i got rid of it
what was it
honda civic okay to purchase
at least isn't that trashy though i
think that's trash rent to buy that's
that's that kind of thing
that's for the guy who just can't lease
or buy a car i released it for three
years then i was like i'll take it
okay have you ever been a member of a
studio audience
i have what was it like when you were
kim oh we got to kimmel all the time
our friend don barros did the warm-up so
we went all out
that doesn't count yet yeah yeah we went
and saw yon when she was on
the whatever the [ __ ] that was the view
or not the view
of meredith vieira yeah we all went like
me monroe yeah sure that's fine
you overly cheerful and stuff yeah and
then but like the the the ho
the comic who was doing warm up brought
us down like we just like ended up
playing
like the improv games and [ __ ] with them
really it was like fun yeah yeah yeah
that's funny yeah that is fun no it's
fun to be that's just when you know
somebody got to meet lamp
lance bass too really yeah yeah i want a
little body on him good looking guy
it's fun when you get out of towners or
normcore people take them to a studio
audience
yeah well that's the trash if your mind
is blown by like we went in we're like
oh we need
this is fun kitschy type thing but
people go there and they're like i get
the free radio today oh my god
how about the people who stand out in
front of the today show and look in the
house just to be like
is that [ __ ] nuts you came all the
way to [ __ ] new york
matching [ __ ] t-shirts that say
[ __ ] bill's birthday
like hi mom dude i went to uh snl and
che took me around like give me a little
tour afterwards
and uh i was like oh is that that door
you come in and there's nothing behind
it it's just like a wall it's like a
fake door
and i was like i come in through it he
goes and he goes i won't because i think
it's bad luck
i think it's a jinx that you'll never be
the one hosting if you come out
and i was like oh and then i was like
but can i do it
let's put it to tricks i'm like dude
it's not gonna yeah that's not on my
[ __ ]
job
[Laughter]
i can see that though what do you got
kip um
okay have you ever used the chili cheese
machine at a 7-eleven
come on yeah who hasn't yeah
that's i don't know what they put in
that chili when you think about it
people are a lot of garbage people yeah
oh dude that's why this podcast is
successful because everybody's [ __ ]
trash you know
garbage it's a theory i never made work
on stage so i'll say it here
garbage is it's just the n word garbage
people is the end
that's that's their garbage people
and then you have like whatever the long
island trash is
jews have the hasidics it's like
everyone
every group and every like geographical
area has their own garbage
we have like long island [ __ ]
whatever yeah yeah it's like jersey
track
that's our version of like that's not
the east village
metropolitan people sure of course but
who's new york's garbage people it's
that and there yeah
or white trash is white people's trash
yeah
yeah garbage comes in all shapes and
sizes yeah it does it really does
and you see people pull themselves from
garbage but it's also like generational
like you're like i grew up like my
family's garbage
so i'm garbage so like my kids will be a
little less garbage like if i do
if i get because i'm learning and i'm
like because like you hang out with
different people and you're like oh [ __ ]
you don't do that you don't
you know it's like all right i got to
stop [ __ ] cleaning my car at the gas
station
you grew up and you're like oh i didn't
know you shouldn't do it well you also
become shameful in it like if i ever
caught my kid
washing his car at the gas station i
would [ __ ] hit him like dude we don't
[ __ ] do that [ __ ] yeah they're like
but dad you did i'm like
i don't anymore i did it so you know
you're not gonna start yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i know we've come a long way i yell my
nephew when he's picking his nose
don't be doing that you still do it
meanwhile i'm in there
you ever get caught in the car what all
right so you're picking your uh
well let's go into this you're picking
your nose in the car yeah what do you do
with it you buy yourself
i will occasionally eat i eat more than
i show
wait a minute wait a minute wait not as
much as in new york cause you know it's
dirty out here but in general
wait yeah i'm i'm a booger eater i'm not
proud of it but
what but i will admit it okay he's got
booger booger eater written all over his
face
it's not the hussids you put him in a
lineup he's a booger eater for sure wait
oh i'm eating them holy
[ __ ] you're garbage i mean for that
it's gross you're hitting us with this
that's a dead guy it's an
old guy i'm not like that anymore you're
eating [ __ ] boobs i understand it's
problematic and i have a disease
it's part of my body and if you shame
before it's body shape all right let's
say
let's say the wet ones too the white
ones the white ones the more the
wetlands
the super dry ones that's garnish
[Laughter]
that's panko breading um all right so
say you don't eat it let's live in a
world where you don't need it for some
reason you just had a big lunch a big
special
car driving yourself you're in the car
what do you do with it in the car
i will eat it i'll collect make a bigger
and bigger ball
eventually you get a ball that's big
enough and you find a car
nearby that makes you think worse about
yourself okay bmw
mercedes anything like that and then
that goes on that car
just a nice slick out the window and
it'll stick the proper etiquette
is pick and flick it's like where out
the window or
in your car oh of course out the window
of course i'll go under the seat dude
don't go under my seat
i'll tell you that it looks like it
looks like a bunch of isotopes on a cold
winter day you're gonna pick and then
roll down the window now so come on what
are you doing
i got caught the other day at a light i
had one in my hand i didn't really
i had my wind my hand out the window and
i was rolling what are you doing buddy
and some dumb dude was just looking at
me rolling out like
trying to like fake like i brought it
back in and just held it down in the
seat
dude what do you want from me dude you
eat boogers
jesus christ how often all right we
talked about this briefly
if you're doing your nail like if you're
cutting or you know you're trimming your
nails
how often will you take out a nail
clipper do you own a nail clipper
i do okay got one at barcelona oh
international yeah yeah it says sakura
familiana one of the most beautiful
temples in the world
i'll almost never use it i just bite
you're a biter toenails rip
wow yeah toenails you gotta you gotta
crack it down and you gotta open it like
a bag of cheese after the shower
just like a little bit get a little
crease going and then like oh it's nice
and blue i got it that feels good
i gotta feel it all the way out yeah ah
i can feel it on my toes right now i
love it
and um are will you do that in front of
people like
if you're your girlfriend or wife or i
don't know i don't i i
sometimes i'll lose sight of what i'm
doing and i'll be picking up my toenail
just like you know on the couch was like
start starting it and then i realized
i'm like i better stop what about the
booger eating have you ever done that in
front of anybody no i don't do that yeah
i have to gross them out on purpose but
not like
yeah not casually i know that's shitty
so
you gotta you know you gotta yeah you
gotta keep you gotta play close to the
vest a little bit
at the same time exactly yeah yeah yeah
you can't just [ __ ] broadcast isn't
it
um you gotta have faults you just know
what they are you know what's real
[ __ ] trash that i want to fight the
person every time i see it
go is people cutting their nails
toenails or fingernails
on the subway that's crazy it's insane
that's crazy so you wouldn't do that you
wouldn't
no way that's not that's you saying i
don't care about society
and this is i'm in my own bubble that
happens in new york only
not in london where it's also crowded
but it's only because we're all here
we're animals
and we're like no one else exists
there's too many [ __ ] people that is
a savage move
[ __ ] sad that's i don't care eat
numbers i don't care about girls i'm
it's
putting your makeup you should be
embarrassed but yes doing value out of
your mind
crazy evil here it's crazy and dude
nobody will check that person they just
do it
it's like kind of tell him i know so if
it was your friend you'd be like
what the [ __ ] are you doing if it's not
someone you know you're gonna start a
conversation with the person who's
cutting his toes
on the subway yeah if he's willing to do
that he's got a knife
i saw i saw one guy doing it it was
faking he was standing across from me he
was making my [ __ ] blood boil
and like making my blood boil and then
he [ __ ] stops and i go all right like
i can calm down i'm overreacting because
i'm a bit of a [ __ ] hot head so i'm
like all right just relax you know
and then he pulls out a file and starts
flying like you're putting [ __ ]
fingernail dust in the air
that's pretty classy though i'll give
you oh that's [ __ ] trash that's the
classiest trash
yeah you're filing your nails on your
nails it's a pedicure that's a mannequin
just a movement of it very classy very
pontiff
stuff too much a sandwich or doritos i'm
like all right it's bad but i get it
wet or something right wet food no
you have that out just from spaghetti on
the subway oh yeah
animals it's animalistic those [ __ ]
peppers on a sandwich and like
well dude if you're like yeah it's like
once i'm in the subway i'm like my hands
don't go near my face
oh i'm like it's you know and then well
you got people like [ __ ]
pizza you're underground with a bunch of
dirt balls why are you there's a guy
[ __ ] filing his nails and you're
eating pizza ugh i'm pretty trashy i'm
pretty gross i'll buy churros
down in the subway i'll eat down there
put on a little vacation i'll eat them
on the platform but what really grosses
me out
i don't get is the people that sell the
mangoes
in the ziploc bags because a mango
like you gotta take the whole like it's
the fruit you gotta take all the skin
off
how are you touching that and
negotiating that into the bag yeah
oh no people [ __ ] eat that yeah yeah
for sure you got to cut it and slice it
into
little cubes yeah toothpick you can't
cut a mango when i get mango all over
you
dude the [ __ ] i've never been to a
monster truck show
no i haven't i was so much fun is it a
lot of hot [ __ ] chicks
no dude i swear to god me and my buddies
were sitting around and it was it was on
the tv they were like sunday sunday
sunday we were hungover and it was
[ __ ] sunday we're like let's [ __ ]
go dude
and we went down and dude the amount of
hot chicks was
insane really yes really wait legit
hotter
you could get like shocked that they
were there like they weren't [ __ ]
tens they're not la-10s or whatever but
like
hot chicks wow well you're like what the
[ __ ] is she doing here
yeah you it brings out weird [ __ ] kid
rock groupie kind of
kind of like a little like you know like
they're that's hot t-shirt torn down
yeah
yeah you know like the booty shorts yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah april macy when april
macy started commenting dental hygienist
school didn't work out too well
he's probably some issues with her dad
or her uncle
oh man some highlights in the hair
smells like smoke and perfume
maybe a little little gum
sexy a little bit of stubble around the
mouth what was that
let's go with a short shot and go like
this with a gum oh yeah
yeah trash when uh when was the last
time you had mountain dew
uh uh not this year last year
what nah occasionally totally not nah
and you eat pretty good too right one i
try to eat one healthy meal
four or five days a week and then like
the rest just whatever i want just
shovel [ __ ] into my mouth yeah you're a
tight body on you that's good genetics
yeah it's good genetics honestly
i i eat worse than you do probably yeah
because you're older too
like it catches like i have like friends
like it slows down
yeah oh yeah okay
all right that's a fat guy every other
fat guy i don't know what it is
the same as everybody i know exactly i
hate when a fat guy hits you with that i
don't even eat that much
it's like maybe in public you don't eat
that maybe not though when you get home
you're [ __ ] doing it or if they're
telling the truth like you don't eat
that much but you eat more often
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i only ate one
slice of pizza five times a day yeah
yeah fatness is definitely that is it it
is something that you do alone
oh yeah it's changeful yeah yeah yeah it
is shameful
to eat on the way to go eat they even
meet people to go eat
he'd eat food take out or like uh drive
through on the way so then he could in
front of people just go nobody no yeah
i'm just having a little bit of whatever
oh really yeah he gets we talked i think
we talked about this on that's like
mantle on legion of skanks you do he
gets off the subway
in queens he'll get a burger to
to go because they're like little
burgers from like petey's burgers
shout out to petey's and then eat them
while he walks to the pizza place to get
a slice of pizza
wow hold on oh no you're way worse than
me
okay so i'm i'm hungry yeah all right
it's it's my meal time
yeah that feeding time that is my meal
it's grazing
wait put them out the pasture baby
burger and the pizza are my lunch
okay first that's two things that's not
a lot you get two pds on the way to get
sliced no i get one
one pd one double and then a slice do
you know pd's
i just heard about it recently it's not
really in manhattan though is it no
it used to be out next to the standing
room there used to be one out next to
the standing room as well
yeah i'll stop there i get off the
subway 30th ave i'm walking down
pd's is right there i grab a [ __ ]
double burger i say don't put it in a
bag don't even wrap it up just eat it
i'm
just giving it a napkin great for the
environment let's give credit where
credit's due
he's watching his waste so i like
walking down the street needing i don't
know i feel like i'm in a movie when i
do that i'm into it
it's the direction it's called the nutty
destination is the problem
yeah exactly well okay so i walked down
the street to a bookstore
like that nobody has a problem next to
my apartment is a pizza place that i
like so i'll get one burger and a slice
of pizza
what's the difference how many times is
it one burger and more than one slice a
single and a slice maybe but you're
getting a double and i'm gonna guess
more than once two more slices for sure
a specialty sure
[Laughter]
because i got a penny slice i'm not
walking away what about your [ __ ] ass
now that's a burger pizza and pasta dish
yeah they put it on that's a big that's
a big lunch
i love it dude i just had we were
hanging out in the village drinking
and uh wayne got a grandma slice from
ben's
that i haven't had in months fresh one
oh yeah there's nothing or slice
dude how great is this [ __ ] pandemic
where those little things you're like oh
yeah this place is awesome
dude yeah we went hung out of the room
the bar that we always get
uh drinks at in the village shade it's
on like it's right it's right on third
and we're like hanging out there and
then went to get a slice of pizza i'm
like oh i feel normal again i'm like
this is this is comedy in new york you
know yeah
for a minute it feels totally normal
like yeah you forget it and then like it
reminds you their first week here in new
york or whatever where you're like this
is funny this is the greatest i can do
that i could just do this i'm just gonna
get a burger and a pizza and then
whatever let's start my evening this
guy's [ __ ] sidetracking us again um
because we were getting close to him
yeah he does he he pivots really he does
this kid's got a good pivot
yeah um you see bonus features on are
you garbage
patreon check us out there he's smoking
weed again really support lois
come get him um what uh
legit now did you leave the house with
the roach that i would say
yeah you're also [ __ ] successful i'm
probably got a bunch of weed at the
house i know i do but i was like i don't
want to
pick a whole thing i just i see one i'll
grab it and it's good
and what happened out of it you guys
watch that i'm good thank you how come
you're still smoking you're not on the
drops or the gummies or anything like
that well they're
on everything
shout out to hims.com we just got my
shipment in
but you still prefer to smoke a joint
yeah sometimes it's
old school like 30 minutes you know you
know what's really trashy when smokers
clip their cigarettes and put it back in
the pack
that's trashy oh yeah yeah and then
you open it up and you ever borrow
people
what the [ __ ] is this dude yeah it's
like you're smoking another somebody
else's
ashtray ugh yeah just throw it away dude
i don't know did you use this smoke for
a little while
when i worked the door at the store okay
after a while being around where
everyone go smoke and eventually you're
just like started sure
sure it's definitely a social thing
comedy yourself i might get you with
this
so you were poor probably at the time
okay right
i'm assuming like when you were like
working the door smoking sick probably
not a lot of cash
no not a lot of cats would you see a sig
on the ground that someone had flicked
and pick it up and smoke it
all right no but i have looked for that
before oh
looking for it yeah um
yeah well dice well dice would always
like not use he would chew on his
cigarettes and throw him out
so you could find a good diced one
wait a minute he wouldn't like he would
chew on them yeah he didn't want to
smoke he didn't smoke for a long time
and but he'd still like the doing this
and occasionally that needs to
just chew on it for about the amount of
time it took to smoke a cigarette and
then you flick it out and get another
one
it was crazy and they were like benson
hedges oh so [ __ ]
dice brand yeah and he would always do
that and so it was the option would
sometimes ask a really annoying person
to borrow a cigarette no that means he's
going to want to talk
to you for like a week or two right or
like let me look in the ground first and
see if there's any like dices
yeah you probably had they probably
wanted to talk to you too because you
were the adult like you weren't there so
they're like oh i'll hear all right the
other annoying door guys
james in particular you can take it from
fat he's dead i can talk about him shout
out to pat james
rest in peace big man shout out to fat
foley too um
uh yeah that was the two options and
it's like [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] trashy yeah that that is
damn i've made some mistakes that's a
homeless guy [ __ ] yeah yeah
i mean we did it when we were like 12 or
i never did it but my friends would like
we would be like skating wait they'd be
all
flat from being yeah well like someone
would walk into like to the you know
we'd be
outside of like uh i was like crazlers
or krauser's [ __ ] like
kwik-e-mart and somebody would like hop
out of their car flick the cig and walk
in
and my friends would like go like look
into smoke and like grab it and [ __ ]
[ __ ] smoke i could never bring myself
now dude
imagine it seemed okay i know because
we're dude that don't seem bad but
oh no i don't know i don't even and i'm
disgusting
we know this now i don't i don't like
sharon when somebody says hey let me get
a drag in that
oh no i do i'll give you one no i don't
want a whole one well i don't want to
fight
what are you talking about whatever you
want crazy yeah yeah
because there's two things that grossed
me out one is the the wetness of of
somebody else's saliva on it
and some people pull cigarettes really
hard
and they hand it back to you and it's
like burning hot
you're like what the [ __ ] it's like
giving you a hot piece especially when
that bronze i just want one puff you
want two so you go you know
yeah you go yeah you make a calendar
yeah smoke a [ __ ] cigarette if you're
sharing sigs what are we doing here
you know what they should make they
should make half these cigarettes little
guys
they do have they do have little guys
they do make the 72s marble makes the
72s they're smaller but like
i mean like take a regular cigarette put
that amount of
whatever but like you know how it's like
this long sure you just cut it right
there and have filter
yeah they do have so you can have a 40
pack of hazzies oh
the pierre same size even get downstairs
i think
get that let's get a warning [ __ ] who's
the [ __ ] dylan get on
you know just one call phillip pups do
you
eat peanut butter and jelly i i
sometimes yeah have you ever gotten
peanut butter and jelly that came
in the same jar i had before in my life
you have bought it yeah it was trash
well well well
mr 1250 over here old that's a 13.50
still buying his pb and jack in the same
[ __ ] you see it on the shelf it was
innovative at the time you're like let
me at least check it out
all right i'll really see what is this
i'll give you um the innovation aspect
i'll give it to you it was a brand new
product that's a good case it seemed
like it was this genius or not i don't
know
one time thank you i'll give you the one
time for sure it's just you'd be crazy
not to at least examine it
that was yes they've been separated for
millennia
they're suddenly in a jar you're [ __ ]
the [ __ ] like i'm not even gonna
give it a try
yeah no i love when we get him on one it
gets so mad
what time it's been 15 years or more
i'll give you that you got it yeah
that's a pass that's a pass
hey gang today's episode is brought to
you by sheath underwear it's the summer
it's hot it's sweaty out there and
that's why you need sheath
yes you do i got them on right now i
swear to god camouflage sheath
is the softest most comfortable boxer
brief i've ever worn the fabric has
silky
feel to it and it keeps everything cool
comfortable in place there's multiple
pockets
it's awesome i love it my wife calls on
my sexy underwear
here's what makes sheath unique it's got
a pouch so you can separate
your dick from your balls the franks and
the beans
this is huge for the summer especially
if you're working out outside
now here's the thing all right some of
you folks out there might not be
interested in separating your parts and
hey let's be honest
some of you probably can't okay but i'm
almost defensive
so am i i'm right there in the middle
but here's why we still recommend sheaf
is because you can wear it just like any
other boxer boxer brief
yeah and they're super soft throwing
super comfortable they're absolutely
[ __ ] fantastic
and i find it easier to take a leak in
them which is great
and the one more thing is they [ __ ]
look good they're so cool looking
if you're looking for something to take
some sexy pics do a little this do a
little
little sex thing as it gets over at the
ryan household after a couple of glasses
of box throw a couple of pics my way
sheath is the underwear you want to be
using so do us a favor gang
go to sheath underwear dot com to get
your pair of smart underwear
and if you use promo code garbage how
much
kippy what do they get hit me big man
lay it on me twenty percent
not your order twenty twenty yikes
[ __ ] twenty percent do it that's a
wrap cannot beat that deal
gang that sheath underwear dot com use
promo goat garbage
and let's get back to the show do it um
growing up would you guys do or at any
point like you know your 20s or whatever
were you more of a dominoes or pizza hut
guy or
family because there's a big difference
yeah we were worth the next jews we
couldn't get either one of those
so no pizza i worked at domino's later
but
no we had uh we had uh jaffa gate for a
while it was the upscale pizza place and
the
harry's nuthouse pizza which still
exists some of the worst pizza in the
world
harry doesn't know his way around the
pie what is it kosher what's it it's
kosher but it's just
terrible it's just salt is the main
ingredient it's it's pretty good right
out of the oven
by the end of the slice it's already
congealed
it's dude that just made my blood run
yeah and you're like oh i'm glad i got a
second
and you're like and she's like hard oh
it's so bad and it's like
dirty there it's like always getting
shut down because of roaches and [ __ ]
and then like
oh dude i'll deal with a roach or a
mouse for a good slice like if i told
you
somebody had it i would do it but not
for harry's you know what i mean mexico
wanted to tell you about my moons he
goes oh dude there's my stomach she
stops outside i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna not go there just i don't
wanna hear any of this the moon's hot
so good something else i missed that
when new york was shut down i missed
that go grabbing a [ __ ] they're
like cheap what were they like you know
five bucks or something you eat they
look awful yeah
that's warmer though that place in the
in percy's pizza on uh
that's a solid dollar that kept us alive
when you've been there
for the first two years living up here a
hundred percent mm-hmm
still dabble too go back to go back to
the old stomping grounds you know what i
mean
i took a cow i was here with rogue once
opening for him i took a cab from like
midtown
to my moons just to get it there
i would do that too if you were just
here for the you know if you're just in
town
all right let's stay on food a little
bit yeah and go for it uh i want to know
if you've ever taken ketchup and
mayonnaise and mixed it together
and made russian dressing out of it you
gotta change these questions from ever
too often or when's the last time you
ever is just like you have people that
aren't embraced
people who have done it once and people
who do it every single day of their
lives i told you
what a giant umbrella you've made that's
crazy
all right so what's the answer how often
mr shafie or when was the last time
once maybe ever have i mixed them
together and it's been
well over 15 years okay all right okay
all right you can't pump me with those
people
all right but you bet you stuck your toe
in the water when's the last time you
ate a booger
i mean i do that a lot i will admit to
that i will admit to that a definitely
okay
all right okay not today um what's yeah
[Music]
that all right sure that one you got me
on gg
he's so pissed dude it's just some of
these questions they're ridiculous
have you ever it's nuts have you ever
shared your pants yeah when i was a
[ __ ] kid
but also an adult that's so that you can
judge me that's going to go and i've
been [ __ ] your pants as an adult
so many times like full [ __ ] like no
uh like act like i mean just like a
little [ __ ] no no
art unload like i'll uh yeah like a this
much
what yeah yeah for the audio listener
you just held up a coffee cup full of
turds
yeah one time for sure hard and then
yeah i definitely
like not just you know when it doesn't
just line the underwear like not skid
marks but like
it's like [ __ ] though but like like that
level but then like
long oh you know well that's not that
bad i took off that
dump in my pants when about a year ago
why
uh i was i was working on something and
i had just gotten done and i was too
what does that mean working on something
that sounds so vague when you're talking
about something horrible i was working
you played a fat guy or something i was
working on the show okay and i was too
scared to [ __ ] in the trailer because i
was leaving
okay like i was done for the day and i
really had to go and we were filming out
in uh republic airport in long island so
it was about
about an hour to get home and i really
had to go and i got stuck in traffic and
i was just dying
i was dying and i got the car parked and
i got about 25 yards to my apartment
and just stopped no just [ __ ] and i got
all the way back
yeah didn't make it oh it was you know
you know you could if
it was halfway back you'd be like i
didn't have a chance i didn't have a
choke
so close you know you can fight it you
get that like close and it goes away the
worse it gets
oh yeah it's like you start do you start
fumbling with the keys
you got a turtle head popping and it
wasn't it was a full
[ __ ] like my dad you could feel my
underwear
much heavier really oh i've never done
it bad i had to throw everything out it
was awful
it's like a murderer oh it sucks so bad
uh the
the underwear is done everything was
done the pants are probably
if i know she's standing up too yeah he
shouldn't have stopped to get the burger
though
i'm wearing the jeans that i ship my
pants in are you really yeah yeah i
saved my jeans
yeah because i had to get back i thought
underwear out i had yeah jeans
yeah and then once i got back i chucked
them what do you just wash them you
gotta wash the dryer at home
no no he took him somewhere i put him in
his house
i was i threw my underwear out and he's
trashed no they're done
you're crazy those jeans are done you're
crazy
the bad juju on those jeans to begin
with you don't know how hard it is i
mean the the bad luck you have with
those yeah for that reason alone but
also
you did [ __ ] all over them now
i put them right in the shower and
watching those treats are done yeah
you can throw them away yeah so they
don't smell in the kitchen
oh you don't know how hard it is for a
fat guy to find a pair of jeans that fit
perfectly it's hard you ever sit in the
tub
no yeah i i thought i was farting and
it well it wasn't that's
i mean it's in there like swimwear as a
kid right my wife was upset
what you did this year i can't hang it
have you done that recently
i've done it as a adult yeah it was
within the last five years why were you
taking a bath
i take baths that's a vlog
dude get yourself first of all go get
yourself a [ __ ] robe too that'll
change god guys
i got a big blue robe big tommy robe
bath
no one bothers you you can justify being
in there read joint
dude i get like the ipad going or
something yeah some tunes
sometimes glass of wine yeah oh come on
glass of red wine throw in a bath bomb
dude everyone leaves you alone
yeah if you live with the chick she's
not i'll touch you because that's her
dream she understands how [ __ ] great
it is of course dude
i'll turn the lights off get like the
ipad going or laptop some
a glass of wine and like that dude show
like shirley my girl like wow like the
candle light a candle and i'm just dude
full-blown it's great dude
big bath guy holy [ __ ] i want to get
bubble bath
if i had a dream apartment it would have
a bath that i could really just like
yeah oh yeah
dude with the with the claw feet that's
what you ever you know what i mean like
oh yeah yeah that's real
i just don't [ __ ] them and it's annoying
yeah it's hard sometimes you got to go
legs up like that and it's just not as
fun
i got a big deep one though it's nice
yeah oh that's great dude i'm going to
have one today
dude i wanted we got a place in hawaii
we're staying there
some like airbnb and the shower was
outside and then they had a bathroom
outside i was all alone on some [ __ ]
like tree farm or something that's how
you just sit back there and just look at
the stars
oh god damn about it it's good you are
an outdoorsy guy you love the outdoors
yeah
man of the wilderness oh that camping
that's the best place to do drugs
camping is pretty good i like how you
were about to judge us for the bath but
we went so hard on it yeah i don't
know like okay well that's something
you didn't stick to it it's nice um i
wish i could take advantage i think i
only got
one or two left here let's see let's
make them
worth it let's make it worth it not like
what wasn't worth it which is what greg
fitzsimmons kids did
dump it prank caller prank
[Laughter]
you ever called a sports radio show yeah
we yeah when the wtem started in north
carolina maryland we said
cornheads are at a show on late night
and there was like no listeners we'd get
in regularly
and just like what chop it up about
sports he started to recognize your name
after a while
we got ari down here in maryland are you
my brother's name from merrill yeah no
spring it was back then that's me yeah
they would just know you
don't want to listen to us a brand new
radio station was [ __ ] awesome i
wouldn't wait in line like like big fan
like pat and oswalt
yeah what about time share
no i've never done that you ever sell
them no i've never sold them
you've ever gone to a pitch for one to
get a free weekend not even done that
hmm i would probably have gotten roped
into that at some point if somebody hit
me at the right time but like hey yeah
come for a weekend
uh all right sounds okay i guess and
then you're just there
dude i don't know what it is it's like
the blue collar garbageness in me that
it's like
and i just my family just goes anything
where someone wants to give you
something
is a scam for sure if you're walking
through the mall and someone's like hey
do you have a second i'm like i don't
know i don't care what you have but it
ain't for me yeah
like if there's no way it benefits me
you wouldn't be stopping me or be like
hey
come here for the weekend absolutely
never going to be good yeah and
and the thought the reason you're older
it's like what are we rude what if it is
good you know
if it is good they'll find someone else
to get it of course so like who gives a
[ __ ]
yeah we had the i know this happens in
new york we had the
person show up at my parents house when
i was home uh
the last couple weeks to switch our uh
power over yeah from from pico to
just other things some third party she
was so
she was like well if you just give me
their i think you know i was talking to
your dad before is your mom or dad here
i'm like nah they're not interested
cause you know she's trying to [ __ ]
hustle them she's like well if you just
give me their names i can sign them up
i'm like
get the [ __ ] out of my lawn the [ __ ]
the matter with you
mm-hmm that's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
they signed me up these two
these two yeah that's what i was
thinking because in like in the city
they just get into the building
and they're like young you know like
[ __ ] they just like knock on the door
and he's like hey can
you have you go say i'm from the power
company and i'm like oh yeah i'm like no
you're i'm like he goes let me see your
bill i'm like
i want to sign you up for some [ __ ]
he goes like he goes out there they go
you have to right don't they say
yeah yeah and then i'm like dude i don't
want to i'm like no i'm good he goes
well let me just see your bill he goes
i'm not i'm not offering anything i just
need to see your bill go what do you
need to see my bill for
and he goes we just got to make sure
you're getting the right you know what a
meter read it you're talking about nah
man i'm good he goes
dude we just need and then he's like my
manager is right here and it's just like
some other
other person some other teenage kid and
i'm like i don't [ __ ] know him or you
yeah
so what they saw they say no we're here
collecting data for whatever and i'm
like i don't know
the two i saw were both black so i felt
like i'm not trying to be racist here
but i have no time for this
you sign up but they signed me up
without without they just got somehow
got my address or something like you
have to i'm like you'll be back
i'm leaving right now i i don't know if
it's that important you'll see me again
or something i don't want to kick him
out of the building too
i'm like hey you you don't live here and
this package is here mm-hmm
yeah you are those people you ever steal
somebody
what a great scam of course everybody's
like you're the power company you get oh
you know who i got called by uh
yesterday that i used to do this is a
real scam [ __ ] so you know like the
fraternal order police
they're like uh you know you'll get like
the bumper sticker or the sticker for
the back of the window like hey friend
of the cop or whatever like
it's because they raise money you have
to donate to get one of those stickers
but cops can't call cops and fire
departments can't call
and try to raise money because that's a
conflict of interest
yeah because it'll be like hey you know
you better hope there's no [ __ ] what
you know
so there's just they're not allowed to
do it so they sub it out to these
[ __ ] dirt bags the dirtbag call
centers and i did it
and i didn't know it was like hey i
needed the money it was like paid
training 500 bucks a week for the first
two weeks i'm like well there's a
thousand bucks
in the next two weeks uh that's all i
need so i show up it's
under 95 in philadelphia it's like under
the highway and i'm like what the [ __ ]
can we walk in
and here they call and you gotta you
don't say you're a cop
but you like a loot they change your
name they go what's your name i go kevin
he goes ah you're gonna be jim mcnulty
so i'm like hey what's up this is
mcnulty i'm calling with the you know
the sheriffs whatever like and you gotta
be real vague and people you just
fleece these old women out of money and
then they send a van to go pick up the
money it's so [ __ ] shady
yeah and then they got a friend of the
cop don't give me a ticket yeah exactly
yeah you know those stickers i'll get
you know for for a hundred bucks i'll
get you a sticker and then the police
only get fifty percent of it
wow the rest because they look oh well
fifty percent
you know the [ __ ] susan g komen nfl
once you know how much they get that's
pennies dude three percent
of three percent goes to [ __ ] breast
cancer research
that's the biggest scam nfl gives three
percent to the susan g komen
foundation if you guys buy a hundred
dollar jersey three dollars goes to
susan g komen okay
of the three dollars goes to suzucomen
only nine
cents goes to breast cancer research the
other goes to paying people who work
yes marketing [ __ ] all that marketing
yeah the team that's on the nfl project
their salary
what the [ __ ] we're all nine cents every
100
jersey we're all [ __ ] trash
all right i think i just got one more oh
that guy this is
how do you feel about the rotisserie
chicken from a supermarket bingo
okay i haven't gotten in a very very
long time well what are your thoughts
what are your thoughts and feelings
really good if somebody ever said like
i've gotten that i'm like that is really
delicious and it's like four bucks for a
whole bird no juice that's
awesome dude you can make a whole meal
of it carb free pretty much
hard for me for sure get a veggie cider
it's so juicy
you think so too right oh right but you
know it's embarrassing you can't really
say that it's a garbage thing if you're
yeah when you see somebody with one of
those [ __ ] little bubbles in line
you're like this [ __ ] dirt bag
but i tell you what you know it's good
you're still like yeah yeah
dude you would never admit it i'm the
same when i catch somebody picking their
nose i'm like ew
yeah exactly it's judgment yeah yeah if
you guys have stuff that you know is
awful but like you still like i know but
i love it oh yeah food wise
or anything in general where you're
going to i know this is terrible you're
right to judge me on it but yet
i still like it smelling my own farts
that's a big one
everybody likes their own uh right what
is that
it's in you it's party it's like having
a little kid or something you know weird
but i love it
but anybody else is like yeah it's tough
um i like the the musician oh yeah
for sure dude yeah for sure
yeah yeah we should not no but she could
do it
you got to think about it she's got
these like [ __ ] million dollar
producers behind it to know
how you to know what kind of music
tickles the brain
yeah but that's not that kind of music
it's not supposed to tickle my brain i
know but it's a math equation it's not
up to your brain
your ear just goes this is what humans
this
admitted that we is that she comes out
constantly i'm like who is this this is
great
like pink am i [ __ ] again um all
right this is my last one this is a
common one
what is the grocery store you go to um
closest grocery store always closest or
whole foods
well there you go that's class i'll give
you that new york it's new york's it's
proximity but yeah
i would say i would say the closest
whole foods
is the one i will go to okay do you keep
your ketchup after you open it in the
fridge or in the cabinet
bottle of ketchup fruit okay what about
syrup
what keep it in the fridge you keep it i
can't almost never have syrup okay
what about baked pancakes a lot let's
look at them there's syrup in my house i
mean ari what the [ __ ]
and it's in the cabinet like a goddamn
gentleman um
i keep my syrup where it should be at
the restaurant i go to yeah
at the diner yes um what
where do you keep the butter on the on
the counter or in the refrigerator
pushing for counter
lately and they keep it out that's trash
they keep it on top of the fridge
columbia on top of the fridge
it's dairy sauce i know but shut up
you said it was your opinion yeah
europeans also keep their eggs on the
[ __ ] shelves
i don't know what they're doing how
about on these high level
[ __ ] fridges that are out now we get
a setting for just butter which is
higher than the rest of the fridge
this guy's a [ __ ] idea keep it at a
cool 60
yeah 70 55 maybe that's a [ __ ]
great idea right yeah open it for the
inside of the out or whatever
little butter sweet let's invent that
come on ari
that's pretty good pepsi cigarettes all
that yes good invention
out there last question how often
yeah when was the last time yeah you
can't ask whatever
you had breakfast for dinner um
i'll have it occasionally at diners did
you have do you
have you ever made it like no mate
scrambled eggs after seven people yeah i
mean
that's trash if you're doing it maybe
after shabbos once in a while but
naughty
nah yeah that's a breakfast food it's
food it's a divorce dad move too
breakfast for dinner i'm your big
divorced ad move if you're drunk you hit
me in the fast food and suddenly i'm
like what the breakfast is still
available
and then maybe oh yeah [ __ ] that but
the gloves are off if the mcgriddles are
hot suddenly at 10
mcdonald's started doing that man that
blew my [ __ ] mind i loved it
i will not go to mcdonald's anymore no i
haven't been to mcdonald's in [ __ ] 15
years yeah how come
it's disgusting trash it's not food
sometimes you get the breakfast sandwich
it's got like that [ __ ]
yellow yeah it's like what nothing's in
this shape
i think it's delicious and they make a
quality fine product the ribs are in rib
shape
with bone in i don't get that
i stop at the shamrock shake that's her
that's where i go with the novelty items
that mickey mouse
it's all trash i'm [ __ ] quarter
pounder nothing
all right ari shafir what's your verdict
he's [ __ ] garbage eats boogers
that was it that's the determining
factor one hundred percent uh you got a
couple
of blood you should do it you said you
regularly
when was the last time you ate a booger
no that happens all the time you're
right on that
i'm just saying some of these questions
let me [ __ ] be
i don't know whatever sure
what kind of friend are you would you
bail somebody out of jail what did you
do
you're right those people would you drug
a friend yeah absolutely
i'm a good friend free drugs
if they knew they were gonna enjoy it
for sure well obviously i
i've always gotten that vibe from me
that you that you're you're a good guy
you're not a bad guy right right that's
right there's a difference you could be
a good guy who's trash
yeah you're a good guy you would if
somebody came in here and like [ __ ] yeah
you're right you're right i'm wrong
those are the
questions have you had him on yet
we did it we played it on legion of
skanks okay because i mean for sure he's
trash yeah we want to have my i can't
wait to hear his growing up
oh yeah um him now i mean he's
he's still trash he's he still walks in
that world a little bit
you see that and you're like well
sometimes i'm over there at this house
and i'm like we're talking i'm like
it's just like he's like what i'm like
how are we friends
all his [ __ ] books on his show for
autobiographies of sports
yeah that's awesome i go over what
novels you have it's like
no balls no vowels
joe namath biography yeah the brian
dawkins
life in times of beat dogs
bernard hopkins on bernard hopkins i'm
leaning great guy
great guy garbage horse garbage humor
great guy
raised the comics yeah you're you're
like a [ __ ]
robin hood to younger comics oh really
yeah yeah everybody loves you what do
you mean you gave all that [ __ ] away
when you moved you just posted a sign in
new york comedy
uh new york comedy club's green room hey
if you need something get my address got
it yeah come get it get myself i didn't
get anything did you no no no i don't
remember
yeah yeah i'm not that true i'm not
taking trash trash come on it wasn't
true
no i know it was great everybody that
showed up was garbage
everybody that showed up no they're just
poor it's so hard to be a [ __ ] new
newcomer that's tom you gave away a
computer
huh yeah was it an action grill
uh [ __ ] yeah an entire gas grill some
guys at a [ __ ] rooftop in brooklyn oh
okay damn
that's great man yeah you're like a
[ __ ] you're a class act
gotta take care of the young comics
instead of throwing it away
let them know this stuff ain't trash
[ __ ] come get it yeah yeah yeah it's
perfect
you're a good man were you guys ever
poor for when you started comedy or were
you just like did you just
dude
like 700 bucks you seem like you have
money h what don't let the shirt fool
you
you seem like you have something if you
still have a day job you seem like a
decent paying one
no no day job and then bad paying comedy
i know i was
i was i was doing good you're doing it
until the pandemic oh really the acting
yeah you said you i said you seem like
you have money i mean i mean you're
doing all right
from like [ __ ] not being able to pay
the rent right i mean like you can get
as many beers as you want tonight and
you won't think about it financially
i would do that either way yeah i'm
really bad that's why yeah i'm garbage
like that
if i have twenty dollars i'm spending
twenty dollars yeah right and then i'm
waking up the next morning in a panic
oh my god what am i gonna do oh yeah i
dude i'm the king of
if i have 100 bucks in my account i'm
like i'll spend 50 and then take a 40
uber home and yeah it's tomorrow's
problem yeah yeah what a [ __ ] idiot
you guys are
yeah i can budget this [ __ ] better look
like it's new york you can't i mean
if you want to drink a beer stuff like
we're going out to eat do you go or do
you go like
i'll go yeah i mean i have my just spend
it poorly i have cash i just spend it
you're not in danger of like oh i don't
know how i'm gonna
make rent in two months it's possible i
won't no i mean yeah plus my parents you
make all that money for the patreon
and we got patreon cooking shout out to
are you garbage patreon
you got to do it you got to do whatever
practical jokes did you get like they're
the tenderloins when they're on tour
yeah yeah yeah that's why they tour the
tenderloins guys go to patreon.com are
you trash
we're gonna be torn as kippy and the
fatso so lewis doesn't get his hands on
it yeah
baldi and the fat man yeah yeah yeah
just to have that
unaffiliated with gas digital yeah never
heard of them but if you are going to
sign up for guests digital use promo
code ayg
what do you get uh we get to wet our
beak a little bit you want too many i'll
show you the contract all fair
yeah details this guy this guy wants
everything out in the open
i like that that he thinks i have a
little cash on me made me feel you
always seemed like you were fine finally
you weren't like worried like some
people are like [ __ ]
like bernstein doesn't look like it is a
dollar to spend on a sandwich
you know you know what i mean you seem
like you're fine you're like i'll fill
up my car with gas it's no big deal
sure sure put it on the card yeah are
you not
i'm doing fine i'm my parents my parents
have if i need i can i have that yeah
i'm not going to be destitute he's in
bad shape already hanging a lot i'm not
doing great this pandemic [ __ ] me up a
little bit
ladies and gentlemen mr ari shafir aria
is there anything you want the gang out
there to know anything coming up
yeah um where's the camera guys i'm
running for the president of legion of
skanks oh yeah
i will do the best job a lot of people
come and they say i'll do this i'll do
that it's not
okay listen lewis is going to continue
running it because he's never going to
not run it
so that she'll get run as is right
nothing will change with your voting for
him or against him he'll make sure he
gets guests in
all that [ __ ] i'm just there to make the
idea of president
a lot more fun i will only [ __ ] with it
when it's funny
or when i think it's gonna be great but
who else does the best [ __ ] you know i'm
gonna come in there i'm gonna [ __ ] up
their ad reads i'm gonna do what i can
to really have the most fun with it for
myself
you guys are not gonna be the ones that
matter to me i'm going to do it for
myself
so please vote for me the legion of
skanks presidential
elections and i'll continue to [ __ ]
satisfy you guys with constant mayhem
thank you very much
well said ari shafir for president
[ __ ] well said what's all about that
what a fun interesting episode man this
is great guys great podcast
thank you for helping you need to spread
the word i'll [ __ ] do it i'll put it
on my instagram i got a lot of followers
great thank you buddy yeah appreciate it
so much yeah i don't know what else i'll
mention on my pocket i said i'm
on it awesome thank you buddy what are
you gonna tell the gang out there guys
just make sure you rate review subscribe
on itunes and youtube as well full video
available there and if you want to sign
up for gas digital you get the episodes
ahead of time you get the live stream
the chat
all that good [ __ ] plus you get the
library of all the other shows all the
legion of skanks from the past like
[ __ ] nine years
you can go back and listen to all them
uh use promo code a-y-g
and ship us a couple of bucks you know
what i mean right and make sure you guys
follow us on social media follow kevin
ryan comedy
at h foley on ice on twitter foley grams
and kevin ryan comment on instagram and
follow are you garbage on all platforms
yeah and
i'm going to talk to louis to see if you
can make it so you guys cannot have
social media anymore
go all the way one way or the other
totalitarian
everything it should actually h fully
gas digital
yeah shout out to our excellent producer
dylan the kid back there everybody we
love you shout out to louis j gomez
ralph sutton
we love the gash digital family don't
listen to this guy yeah our socks
[Laughter]
we're voting for lewis we'll see you
guys next time
thanks hey gang here's a little bonus
from ahri telling a story about one time
when he [ __ ] his pants
enjoy killing me it really is i [ __ ] my
pants in australia last year
yeah that's not the joke that's not any
part of the joke that's just that's the
informational part that comes at the
beginning
it wasn't when i was a baby by the way i
wasn't like three
i was a year younger than i am right now
i look just like this
but i had kaka in my underpants
i was in sydney australia i was in this
giant bridge it's called the sydney
harbour bridge
it's this giant bridge it looks like the
brooklyn bridge that's just pylons to go
up like this you know like really high
but it's like way bigger and this hike
where you can walk on top of those
things
those steel cables and it's like this
three hour long hike
and i was like 30 minutes into it when i
got my first diarrhea pain
i'm like this is going to be a problem
because i don't know what you guys do
when you get diarrhea but what i do is i
do the diarrhea math
and i figure out where am i on the scale
of one to ten
and that'll tell me how badly i need to
take action right now
because you have to know right now
because that gear gives you no warning
whatsoever it doesn't come on slowly it
comes down at full strength right away
it's not like parkinson's or alzheimer's
no diarrhea is for real
with diarrhoea like la dee da not a care
in the world everything's really sunny
oh [ __ ]
there is here it's here
so you got a one to ten it immediately
you gotta know with one one is like
nothing one is like when this comes out
tomorrow
it's gonna be a bit moist
that's a one that's technically i guess
it's diarrhea
and the tent is like where the [ __ ] is
and i was like an 8.7 like i was pretty
far up there
and uh so i go to the tour guide i'm
like how much longer till we get to the
top
he goes like another hour hour and 10
minutes
all right uh let's see what i'm made of
as a man
you know this is my moment to test
myself
heroes aren't asked to be called upon
they're just called so i just sucked it
up as hard as i could
and i just started like duck walking
up this giant bridge in sydney australia
it hurts so bad it hurts so [ __ ] bad
whatever it feels like to give birth
this was the opposite of that
just one hundred percent pure sucking
it's like a doctor was standing over me
telling us paul
i could see the head oh
i'm [ __ ] trying to do it there's a
scottish guy in line like right behind
me
and he goes pick up the pace please and
i'm like shut your [ __ ] mouth
scotland
i'm working on something right now
oh my god every once in a while i just
get too much like i couldn't control it
and i have to do the cross leg thing
you know you just cross your legs over
as far as you can
do like the reverse splits almost and
then you just stand there
holding it i've seen people like this as
a supermarket before by the way
i have i once saw a lady this peanut
butter aisle just
like frozen mr universe smile on her
face
convulsing rapidly
just like that she wasn't looking at
peanut butter by the way she didn't give
a [ __ ] about peanut butter
she was just trying to [ __ ] herself in
front of her neighbors
until she was like you were good right
back and that's what i was on this
bridge she was like
hold it oh my god oh then
i was sweating so much i was sweating
hard but not in the forehead
i wasn't sweating in the forehead the
forehead that's a sweat of heat or
exertion
i'm sweating under the eye
the sweat of mistakes and regret
but i'm doing it though i'll tell you
i'm in control of the game
for like 54 minutes
until the end of this hike and i have no
idea why but there's this ladder
that just goes straight up for like 12
to 15 steps
and i'm staring this ladder and i'm like
i don't know how i'm supposed to get up
here
because i don't know if you guys can
squeeze your butt cheeks together as
hard as you've ever done that ever
before in your life
and try to bend your knee at the same
time but like you can't like you can't
do it you can't do both at the same time
it's like sneezing with your eyes open
i have no idea why bending the knee like
this that's a release valve
i have no idea why the knee is connected
to the [ __ ]
if you ask me that's a design flaw
it should be corrected in later models
but for some reason you've been that
neat that just opens up the floodgates
so i'm staring this ladder i'm like what
am i supposed to do here
without my knees the scottish guy cast
me in the shoulder
and i'm like what he's like the ladder's
clear and i'm like i know
the ladder's clear braveheart shut up
god you're annoying the scottish people
are annoying people
i get what the english hate you now i
get it
so i'm like all right what am i supposed
to do here why they put a bridge on the
goddamn ladder
beyond me by the way maybe they didn't
expect people with diarrhea to come by
in fairness to them so i was like all
right here's what i'll do i'll take
outside the box i'll just reach up as
high as i can
and i'll grab on with one of the rungs
of a ladder
and i'll just do pull-ups
i'll just step by step i'll just pull my
dead body
up this ladder and it was dead cause i'm
squeezing so hard
from the middle like from here down it's
just dangling away
like joe theismann's leg just hanging
there
so i do like three pull-ups and then i
realized oh i'm very weak
i don't know what made me think i did 12
straight pull-ups
my record was like nine and that wasn't
that was in college like there's
literally no chance i have of doing that
and i get to like four and then i start
doing the shakes
and i brought it to about the nose and i
was like going the wrong way
and then i lost it
and as i let go my right leg it caught
on one of the rungs of the ladder yeah
and you just went like that and as it
as it bent you just you just hear the
sound
this horrible horrible sound
just bent you just hear this
is until you touch your butt you still
are holding out hope
you know that's what we do as humans we
hold out hope
and you're just like please maybe maybe
that one tenth of one percent chance
that it was just a wet fart
please let it just be a streaker
when you reach back there and you feel a
chunk
not chunks anything but chunks
oh and i just stood there for what
seemed like forever like two full
minutes just feeling bad for myself
what is wrong with you ari what is
you're a grown man
you're an american representing your
country in a foreign land
and your underwear is full of wet
kangaroo meat
because you had to get adventurous at
dinner last night
and i just stood there feeling bad for
myself for like two full minutes until i
remembered oh yeah
that scottish guy is still right behind
me
and i'm up three steps so he's pretty
much asked to face right now
so like right in front of him he just
saw the the morse code situation
that was laying out in front of his face
in my pants
was pushing long and shorts
and he just heard the sound he just
heard that
which is an unmistakable sound nobody
ever hears that sound and goes
ice cream truck like that's
never happened
so i turned around to see if he had seen
right this was his face he was going
like this
just staring up like whatever was on his
mind was just wiped off completely
it was just etch-a-sketched right off
like he was like maybe later i'll go to
the zoo and then
his hands were like out like a boxer
just got knocked out but hadn't fallen
yet
and we're just staring at each other
like there's a non-verbal tug of war
going on nobody wants to be the first
one to talk
with his mind he was like how do you
want to play this
and with my mind i was like no no no
it's your move now
i just laid my cards on the table
so this is what he did and he was so
[ __ ] kind he looks at me
he just goes did you just [ __ ] your
pants
that wasn't a nice part by the way that
was just a weird honest question
and by the way if the rules are reversed
there's no way in the world i'm gonna
bring that up
if i'm the guy who heard it then you can
never in a million years he'll turn
around and be like oh crazy weather
we're having
um and uh politics sports and so forth
it's not this time of year i'm never
gonna deal with that
we just went right for it you just [ __ ]
your pants
and i want to lie obviously i'm not
going like the truth on this one right
truth
no i thought i was thinking like just
tell him like a pelican died
or maybe this is what i actually thought
of saying i thought maybe saying like
yeah americans always [ __ ] on bridges
it's good luck but like he wasn't gonna
believe anything
so eventually i just i just i just said
like
yes i [ __ ] my pants
and this is the part that i'll never
forget it was so [ __ ] nice he reached
into his pocket
and he pulled out a handkerchief yeah it
was an embroidered handkerchief
i don't remember the guy's name i wish i
remembered his name all i remember was
initials we're on the handkerchief it
was e-l-m
and he just goes i've been there man
gave me this handkerchief it was so
nice it was so kind on a human level
that was a nice thing anyway i was like
getting choked up almost
i was like dude after i made fun of you
for like an hour straight
about being scottish i was like getting
i was like tears were welling in my eyes
as i reached in there and just started
scooping
just scooping these chunks these twix
travel size
chunks of of diarrhea
and then i released it into the wind
and it sailed away like that feather at
the end of forrest gump